hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown as always
my name is alex and i'm happy to be your
instructor this evening
so tonight we're going to be going over
the knights uh one of the most infamous
pieces in chess it's
besides the pawn it moves different than
everything else
um
and so we're going to be talking about
what some of that means how we can use
our knights to gain advantages
and to start i thought i would just put
out this position here
and the idea is one of the main uses our
knight has is because of its strange
move right so when it moves in an l
shape it goes two spaces in one
direction and one on the other always
and it can go in every direction so we
can see it can go to all of these
squares right now
and again it jumps to get there so any
piece that's in its way doesn't matter
it's always going to jump
and so that lets us do some unique
things and the first of those is
forks so in this position there's
actually two really strong forks
knight to f6 and knight to c7
and the idea of a fork a fork is a
tactic where you attack two or more
pieces or key squares in one move
so if we put the knight here on f6 we
are attacking both the king
and the queen obviously this is very
valuable and one of the reasons the
knight is so infamous is because it can
attack a very powerful piece like the
queen that can move in every direction
because it's just slightly off kilter
it's this again this strange l shape
so that allows us to do things like this
you could also play knight to c7 in this
position forking the king and the rook
and so we're going to be looking for any
time where this pattern is available
where two pieces are
on a square that the knight can hit them
so this is maybe the first thing we're
going to talk about with tonight so
let's go through a few puzzles here
uh here's our first puzzle so it's white
to move and we can see that the position
is about equal right
we both have some pieces developed and
undeveloped
white maybe has a slight advantage
because of their pieces being a little
more centralized but it's still fairly
close but white does have a nice tactic
here
that's going to give them the advantage
so
kind of wants to take a shot in in
person or
on chat feel free to give some
suggestions what should white do to
capitalize on this position
so yeah
so perhaps uh it might not make a
difference but the suggestion is one of
these knights going to d6
if i were playing i would probably put
this knight on d6 just because i don't
want to worry about complications of
them taking my knight here but the idea
is this is uh so what's your point with
uh knight to d6
so i can take it or not
okay
sure eventually the king's gonna have to
move somewhere yeah and then
f7
yeah so this is actually a really
interesting one because
you're utilizing both of these knights
and the check not to get an immediate
fork
but whether i take or move eventually
this will result the same
we use these two nights to
maneuver our knight into a proper avenue
so it could get this fork
so one of the things you always want to
do in these types of positions
is look out for
opportunities of where you might get a
fork so in this position
d6 is the square that let us get there
but we first noticed probably
that f7 here would allow us to attack
both rooks
um the reason you have to go to d6 is a
move like knight to g5 is too slow it's
not calling check and black now has a
move to respond i don't know what the
best move here is but maybe something
like just bishop to e8
um defending
but the point is if we call check
there's no chance for them to do
anything else we're guaranteeing
ourselves this fork
all right next puzzle here
again a little tricky
but uh my one hint for this one is the
order of operations the order in which
we make our moves is important for this
one so how can we utilize our knights to
get a nice fork in this position it's
white to move
okay bishop f7
um king takes f7
um
uh bishop takes
we have this bishop on f8 covering this
nice square so i like your idea we're
recognizing that the king
and these three pieces are all
in a ideal spot for our knight to come
fork
but with this knight and this bishop we
have to be a little careful now the
knight is pinned
um
but trading it away doesn't quite work
because there's still a piece defending
so what else can we try here
any ideas
how do we take advantage of this
situation
okay so rookie one check
normally i would like this move um
because it's bringing our piece in and
it's gonna help attack
i think unfortunately though this is
gonna give black
i think they have a resource here
but i have to see what it is because
they can't just play something like
bishop to e7
because then this would fork
and they can't move their knight in the
way
what is their move
that might be good enough
but i think there's a slight problem so
let me take a quick look
so king to d7
and oh i see
we can't just take this free knight
because then black will take our bishop
and if we take the bishop first then the
rook takes and defends the knight
so
this is close but it's not quite good
enough
yeah so the order here is the most
important thing
ultimately what we want to happen is we
want the king to end up on this square
where the knight is so that when we call
check it forks
if we take here first we can't do it
because the bishop covers and if we take
the bishop then the fork is gone
so as he pointed out yeah we have to
take uh we have to take the bishop first
this basically forces king takes f8 and
after we take the knight the king has
ended up on the perfect square for us to
get our fork
and being able to see that through ahead
of time is really important so
recognizing both of these pieces are
defending this square at least partially
again this piece is pinned
but our ultimate goal is to get our king
to end up on one of these squares so we
have to trade everything off and we have
to trade this last so that our knight
can come in for the fork
hello everybody in the chat glad to have
you all here all right so here's our
next position
maybe this one's a little bit easier but
uh no less tactical how can we gain a
nice advantage here
using our night forks
our theme today is about the night
so
one of the best things about the night
is its ability to fork um but we're
going to be talking about a lot of
different ways we can use our knights
better
okay wandless mugo glad to have you back
in the chat
with the beautiful suggestion queen
takes c6
we're sacrificing our queen
but the idea uh is
this queen is actually overworked it's
defending the knight and the bishop
and what we would love to do is take
this bishop with check with our knight
if we take here first we remove the
defender
and call check
forking the king and the queen we win
our queen back so it's a trade of queens
but we just end up picking up this
bishop for free and so now white is up
uh a healthy piece
so really good find everybody two more
fork puzzles this one's a little tricky
but i want to give you all a chance to
find it so white to move here
find the best move
glad to have you in from brooklyn new
york
see if you can find our answer to this
puzzle
right to move
and if you're struggling a little bit
with this one my hints
uh
is that this actually ties into our
theme from last week which is the pin is
mightier than the sword so pay attention
for some pins so okay so we have
suggestions of bishop takes pawn rook
takes pawn
lots of sacrifices i'm curious what the
follow-ups are for either of those moves
so let's say rook takes and pawn takes
probably queen takes
um and i think the threat is our queen
is going to come down to h7
but i believe black is going to be able
to survive
um
we do have our bishop causing some
threats so let's take a look at this
variation i don't believe this is going
to be our final solution but we can take
a look here
we do have a lot of pressure here on
h7
yeah queen g7 looks pretty good um i
think black might even be able to get
away with rook f7
because we've given up our rook so black
can give back the material
um
and diffuse some of our pressure
queen g7 may also work here um
because i think whatever we end up
getting back isn't going to be as good
although in this case we do have the
nice knight takes
e6
um
so it gets complicated
you would want to put something like the
rook here to
uh pin but unfortunately our queen
covers so i think rook uh d7 or sorry
rook f7 is going to be our move to stop
this variation
uh and i think similarly this is not
going to be quite enough
yes we're going to get some invasion
here but i don't think it's going to be
quite enough this one's actually pretty
tricky
king up then rook lateral
oh you're thinking
we're gonna shuffle our other rook in um
i think that's possible but i think it's
just a little too slow we need something
a little more forcing
like for a strategic advantage it might
be worth sacrificing the rook if you're
playing a longer game
but
but there's a nice tactical idea here
that's even a little sweeter
i'll give a little bit more time if
someone wants to come up with an idea
but again this is a trickier one so it's
okay if you don't get this
all right so i'll help you out with this
one
the hard thing about this position is
there's actually a fork already there
knight h7 the problem is
um
knight takes pawn looks good but
i think pinning is going to be too
problematic but knight h7
with the idea that we're forking the
king or sorry the queen and the rook
and
what do you do the only move that seems
to make sense is to take
but now there's a really big problem i
think you may have spotted some of it
what's the issue here
um
yeah so now we can
we can take for totally free and we get
all the benefits of before
except now uh
we're doing so with check so there's no
time for black to stop it wherever they
go it doesn't make a difference queen to
h7 is going to be checkmate
um so actually in this position the best
move for black is to accept the loss and
probably just play something really sad
like queen f7 allow us to win their
piece
yeah so that was a little crazy you
might not see it during a game
but it does play into our idea of pins
and if we look we can identify these two
pieces are on a really nice fork square
that our knight actually can hit so we
can already be thinking of some weird
things like maybe the knight's going to
come and fork these pieces how do i set
that up well you can try sacrificing but
it's a little too slow
and the trick is to realize oh if we put
our knight here and their king comes in
it's actually
walking right into this pin
so again harder to see don't blame me
for not finding it um but let's move on
to our last example here
all right
uh and this actually comes from a game
uh
fm geller versus miroslav philip back in
1962 in the uh
kurakau candidates so see if you can
find
white's winning idea here
it's a little bit tricky there's a lot
of moving parts in this position but
once you see it it's pretty sweet
so bishop d5 looks really interesting so
what's your idea there
um
yeah so i think this looks good there is
a slight problem
the problem is even though we're forking
the queen and the rook with our knight
here uh once our bishop is out of the
way and taken
the rook can actually call check
so they can interrupt us so if we do
something like this even they could do
it now and mess us up
or they could even wait um
well i guess if they take here it's
actually better for us to take the rook
so probably they have to do it right
away but they can abuse the fact that
it's a check here
um so arcane doctrine is suggesting we
start with knight to d5
i think this is actually going to be a
little more fruitful we found our fork
and now we can look so the problem is
okay well black takes but if black takes
we now reverse everything we just saw
and when we recapture it's with check
so now we force instead of them having
the chance to check and take our rook we
have the chance to check and take theirs
so this that's a little bit about
discoveries which is not technically the
theme of this lesson but all of these
tactics do
meld together
the key is to recognize
well first we see these two beautiful
pieces on a nice fork square and we've
got to figure out what's the problem
this pawn takes is the problem
but actually that is more of a solution
for us in this case so always whenever
you see
a tactical idea it's okay even if you're
thinking oh i'm going to sacrifice
something just look one or two moves
farther just in case
that's the basic idea of a fork and i
know there's some maybe more advanced
examples but just kind of a little taste
of what the knight can do a really
really powerful piece always be aware of
it and it's potential to
just attack stuff that seems like it's
totally protected
next up i want to
shift gears a little bit and talk about
outposts so one of
the real benefits a knight can have in
the middle to end game
is it can become a an outpost or form an
outpost
and to show you what i mean i want to
look at two games here so this one is a
vaseline smithslav versus yosef fruit of
ryakovsky
in the moscow championships 1945.
so let's just take a quick look at this
opening we have a sicilian defense
and e6 a franco sicilian looking to push
d5 and uh
open up the bishop to take if there's
ever a trade
pawn takes pawn knight takes knight to
f6
and we just have some normal opening
ideas white is developing their center
black is preparing to castle
and in this position uh f4 a really
solid move opening up more space uh
white is taking more space and at some
point threatening to push one of these
pawns forward
queen to c7
queen to e1
we trade the knights
e5
and bishop to e3 is played in the game
f takes e5 looks
like a considerable option you might
think of here
but after d takes e5
maybe something like
queen to g3
but looks a little confusing
why can't you just take this oh you
can't take it because uh
it is pinned
so something like bishop to defend
an unpin
and we could see like this nice
variation so f take c5 is a possibility
um
but bishop e3 was what was gone within
the game so let's not get too far down
in the variations
and bishop e6 and i want to talk about
this because this is actually a bit of a
strategic mistake
the problem here is black is going to
spend two moves looking to trade off
light's white squared bishop
which seems good in theory right this
bishop went from not doing anything to
in a few moves it's going to trade off
but this is one it's a bit of a waste of
time
it allows white to gain this space with
pushing f5
um
and it's not really good because white's
bishop was not really doing too much
back here
so wasting two moves to trade it off is
not going to end up being very good and
there's a further problem is now
white is going to start to to recognize
a setup and this is what the important
part with
night outpost is is whenever there's
some kind of like backwards pawn
formation so in this case we have white
has a pawn on e4 that's very strong
controlling the d5 square and black has
two pawns but one of them
uh
is not supported this pawn is backwards
and it's not supported by any other
pawns
so white would absolutely love to get
this knight onto d5
right now the problem is there's another
knight that's gonna trade for it
so what does white do
well they remove the piece rook to f e8
and we just take it and simple enough
knight to d5 and this knight now is
actually a huge monster
so if you look at all of these squares
it's controlling
this knight is a menace for black's
pieces
and the biggest problem is there's
nothing that can challenge it if we
notice it's on a light square
and black has a dark squared bishop so
the bishop can't challenge it
uh black doesn't have any more knights
to challenge it and there's no pawns
again that's the key with it being a
backwards pawn
black's never going to be able to
dismount this knight without doing
anything less than sacrificing a rook
unless white chooses to voluntarily move
it away
so this is an incredibly powerful force
in the center that just puts a lot of
pressure on black for the rest of the
game
in the game the move that was played was
bishop to d8
not wanting to you know double these
pawns and allow white to get an attack
on the king
there's a little too much danger there
uh ideas of maybe again getting the
queen involved rook lifting
so black decides to put this bishop back
uh some people might consider okay well
maybe that's one possibility but what if
i just take this free pawn
queen takes c2
and there's a bit of a problem with this
variation
the problem here is uh it relates to our
forks so does anyone want to try and
find
uh the best continuation here for whites
what should we play as the white pieces
uh so we have ideas of rook c197 so
you're on a very close track there
arcane doctrine
we've noticed that this knight is
primely positioned to fork these two
pieces i think there's a subtle reason
why rook to c1 isn't preferred as the
starting move but i want to confirm
um
perhaps it's just because it's allowing
queen takes b2 and
it's we're going to get a fork here but
we're actually going to be trading two
pawns
uh sorry about that two pawns here and
our knight for one of these two rooks
so
we can do a little better than that
i would recommend starting with rook to
f2 first we're defending our pawn
and then after the queen moves back then
we can play uh rook to c1
and if the queen tries to move off the
line then it's not defending anymore we
can just play knight c7 right away
and if the queen stays on this line
wherever it goes
then we can play rook to c1
so i think that's just slightly better
but the idea is the same
so instead of falling for this kind of
trick
black decides to bring their bishop back
to d8
um
yeah pawns they they do have some value
right in a lot of master games we
sacrifice them for nothing but uh but
it's good to hang onto pawns when you
can
okay so c3 is how white continues here
b5 b3 attacking the queen
queen to c5 check king to h1
and the rook comes to c8
rook to f3 so rook lifting preparing to
likely move the rook over to one of
these squares and begin an attack on the
king side castle
king to h8 preemptively avoiding getting
pinned here
and f6 really really good move
the problem is again this knight is just
way too powerful and we want to start
breaking into our opponent's territory
and black doesn't really have a good
move in the game
g takes f6 was played
but let's look at some alternatives
if bishop takes
f6
then how might white continue
rook h3 so rook h3 is not a bad idea
i do want to play a move before i start
to do that
rook f6 is really interesting um rook f6
might be good enough just because of how
powerful
our knight is i'm actually okay just
taking the bishop with the knight
and yeah we are giving up this beautiful
outposted knight but after something
like queen to h4
there's not really any way to stop all
of our threats
there's just too much happening the
queen is too isolated her pawns are
actually in the way the same backwards
pawn
is going to make it hard for her to
actually get back in time
so this attack is just way too strong
so bishop can't take and g6 also doesn't
work because now we can try and invade
with queen to h4 idea is we're coming
in
or we're doubling up so we have again
too many threats
so something like rook g8
trying to stop our invasion on here uh
actually leads into a really beautiful
idea but if you want to hazard a guess
for go for it um it's actually mate in
two
yeah take on h7 and the problem is the
rook has now smothered the king with our
pawn
so that after we take back
this is checkmate so you can't play rook
to g8 really ever um
so if you try something like h5
the problem is we can just walk right
around it
queen to g5 and there's not really any
way to stop uh queen
coming into h6 if you try king to h7
defending
then just rook h3
and there's too many ideas we're
actually threatening now to take on h5
because uh
once this pawn moves it's actually
pinned to this checkmate square
so
uh for instance just if black plays a
non-move
check
and checkmate
so to try and avoid that something again
like rook to g8 can happen
but we just get the same thing
takes takes and now instead of coming
here for checkmate
it's the same as before we are covering
all of the squares
so let's jump back so for all of those
reasons again stemming from just the
power this knight is exerting and
controlling
uh black played pawn takes
and in this position white played uh i
think the best move queen to h4 with the
same ideas as we've seen
there is a bit of a scary idea in the
game
black played the move rook to g8 but you
might be wondering what if uh this pawn
moves and we create a discovered attack
on the queen
if f5 uh
white has a really beautiful move
so does anyone think they can find the
best move for white in this position
there's probably a few good ones but
one's just the most forcing and most
killer
yeah one less mugo you found it um and
the death cyber right behind knight f6
using our knight again we're cutting off
the bishop and threatening checkmate
this forces bishop takes f6 there's no
other way to stop checkmate
bishop takes and now we take with check
and after king to g8 we can get our rook
involved with check all of these moves
are forced
i'm in here not playing queen to g7
which is actually going to give the king
an escape
you can just play something like work to
g7 amplify the pressure
and you have to stop checkmate so after
a move like rook to e7
very simply rook takes h7
not focusing
wholeheartedly on this one pawn but
realizing now the king is in a very
unfortunate back rank situation
the king is going to have to run over to
e8 and we can call check king to d7
queen takes f5 and just everything is
falling
rook to e6 desperately trying to block
rick takes f7 look here and we just go
back
we went upon
and after rook to h7 we don't really
need to keep going
uh we are going to win this rook and
very shortly after win the game
so all that to say f5 doesn't work and
it all starts from this really beautiful
move knight to f6
so that's why in the game rook to g8 was
played
and here uh this i think will be
our last example for this game the game
continues and we'll look at it but
another really beautiful move here for
white
what does white play in this position
uh rook takes f6
so this looks pretty
good i'm a little concerned so rook
takes i guess the idea is bishop takes
queen takes or knight takes knight takes
rook g7
yeah i think this is like
this is still a i'm happy to be in this
position as white but we are down some
material um
so instead i would just take with the
knight
once again yes this is a powerful piece
so we don't just want to sacrifice it
willy-nilly
but
if we can uh
use it again we're threatening checkmate
and it's going to be similar to what we
just saw
the difference is now
so you can't take the bishop
like we just saw queen takes f6 check in
this case you have to play rook to g7
and we can play something like rook to
g3 attacking the pinned piece
defending
and
i mean there's a lot of moves here rook
to d1 looks pretty simple the idea is
we're gonna play rook
takes d6
and then rook to uh d8
and there's just nothing black can do to
stop it these rooks are totally stuck
this rook can never move or else it's
checkmate
so
you cannot take with the bishop so after
knight takes f6 rook to g7 again
defending the mate but the difference is
we now still have this rook involved so
now
rook to g3
trying to draw this rook away from the
defense
now bishop takes f6 is forced
if you play some non-move like a5
then we have the same kind of idea we
saw earlier
queen takes h7 and after rook takes
now work to g8 the knight supporting
um and obviously you can't take the rook
here because that hangs checkmate on h7
so in the game bishop takes f6 was
played
queen takes and similar to what we just
saw
rook to g8 defending
and ripped d1
d5 was played
rook takes rook takes and rook takes d5
and again there's no way to stop rook to
d8 checkmate or not checkmate but check
mate very soon this rook is pinned
so the queen's going to have to go back
here and defend
but we can still play it because we're
going to force them to give up their
queen
and hopefully you would feel comfortable
winning this position with white
so all of that goes to show the power
again of this outposted knight
black's bishop was forced to play
defense and all of black's pieces were
so cramped because this knight was
controlling so much space
i want to show one more game
that shows the same idea we're not going
to go into as much depth but it's
another really beautiful game also
this is another ussr championship game
from 1956 between isaac bolslovsky and
george litzetson
this game starts again with the sicilian
this time a little more traditional
so nothing too much to worry about here
continuing through the opening moves
both sides are going to activate and get
safe white's looking to be a little
aggressive towards this square
and queen side castles knight takes d4
bishop takes
queen to a5 king to b1 and in this
position black makes a strategic mistake
uh they play the move e5
which looks good
because it's gaining tempo on attacking
the bishop and forcing white to respond
but the problem is as we've already seen
it's making a backwards pawn and it's
actually the same one from the last game
so again by a backwards pawn i mean
there is no pawn
here to defend or help support uh this
pawn
on d6
which means this outpost now is looking
very good we're gonna need to do a
little work
because right now there's a knight that
can go there and there's a light squared
bishop that can support
um but this is something as soon as a
backwards pawn like this is created
something you should have your eye on is
maybe i can use that up
the other reason e5 i don't like is
because black spent some time
fianchettoing their bishop here on g7
and the
e5 actually blocks its scope so you want
to be a little careful of that
but let's continue with the game
bishop to e6
black has recognized the threat of
knight to d5 at some point and just how
important this d5 square is
so they're putting every piece there to
control it and white's going to very
beautifully undermine
all of black's control
in this position white played the move
a3
instead of taking this pawn on d6 which
looks like it's a free pawn but what is
the problem why white made the right
choice by not taking this pawn
how can black continue and cause a lot
of problems for white
yes so in this position uh we're looking
at had white made the mistake of playing
queen takes d6
black can punish this move so what
should black play here
um uh one of these rooks here to attack
the queen
you have the right idea but i want to
switch the order of operations a little
bit because i i really like that idea
first you can actually take here on a2
and the idea is this knight
is defending both this square and this
rook
once we bring our rook in right it's not
as effective if we do it right away
because the knight's defending the rook
so if the queen moves out of the way
somewhere then
let's just say like here this isn't as
it's still good
but it's not quite as good
as if you force the knight to make a
decision
uh so in this case after knight takes
now rook uh d8 and this is actually
almost a mating threat now the knight's
gonna be able to block but
uh you're about to lose a rook
or your queen so
so let's jump back so that's why we
can't take on d6 so white plays a little
safer a3 getting out of the line of
sight of this bishop
rook after d8 now supporting the pawn
and knight to b5 a really interesting
move we're opening up attacks on the
queen and maybe positioning for a fork
here at some point just possibly um but
actually there's a more pivotal reason
for this move that we're going to look
at in a second
queen to a4 deciding not to trade queens
and
white plays a beautiful move that i
would never find so i don't blame you
for not finding it the move here is c4
and this is a strategic sacrifice
because white again wants their knight
to be outposted on d5
so they are sacrificing their pawn here
with the idea that now they can trade
these bishops they don't do it
immediately first they play knight c3 to
gain a tempo on the queen
and after queen b3 then they take
and we've already removed the defender
of d5
the only thing left is to remove the
knight and so just like before bishop to
g5
queen e6 and we just simply take it and
now knight d5 and just again look at the
monstrous outpost that this knight has
it is untouchable and there's so much
space and control and there's so many
threats
so
uh the game continued we're not going to
look at every specific line but i just
want to show you how powerful this is
queen to h4
um and white plays queen to e2 with this
idea that they would rather like they
want to push these pawns but if they go
right now then black can kind of
blockade with the queen
so they stop this idea by playing queen
2 e2
with the plan to move it to f1 and then
they're supporting everything
bishop to f8
because now the bishop and queen are
both trying to defend these squares this
bishop is really having a tough time
because it's gotta try and defend f6
and e7
and maybe even it's supposed to defend
c7 so you can already see that this
bishop is doing way less work than this
knight
queen f1 continuing with the plan rook a
to c8 and g3 forcing the queen back
queen to g5 h4
again sacrificing a pawn but this time
it's a little more obvious why black
shouldn't take it what's the problem
with queen takes g3
so there's a rook on h1 and a rook on d1
so here's the h rook here's the d rook
which of those which ones would you want
to use
this one or the middle one
i guess i would move is that
uh this is two this is three four
so you wanna go here
yeah
so i think this is an interesting idea
um but it's a little bit slow i think
there's maybe ideas of
then pushing this pawn and opening up an
attack on the queen
but i would think in the opposite sense
what if i attack the queen right now
and here's the problem
is so we're defending this rook
but look at what our knight's doing our
knight's covering this really key square
and actually this queen is trapped
arc
every square this queen could go is
covered by one of our pieces
um
and part of that is because the knight
is serving this really firm foundation
here in guarding f4
so you can't take on g3
so instead queen to h6 was played
g4 gaining space and just building
pressure
g5 just trying to stop
white from pushing one of these pawns
black pushes to g5
pawn takes queen takes
and rook to h5
supported by the pawn
again taking up space force on the queen
back and here again we see a really
beautiful move and a benefit
to this knight outpost
white plays the move g5
sacrificing the rook
and in the game black did not take it
black played h6 so why not take the rook
what's wrong with uh black taking this
rook
um well we could attack it but we don't
want to trade queens if we're down a
rook
yep
this queen now leaving the space this
bishop had to pick if it wanted to guard
here or here
and it chose poorly
this knight is threatening too much so
we can actually afford to just hang this
rook because you can't take it it's
guarded by a tactic
so that's why h6 was played
leading white to play rook takes h6
again sacrificing the rook this time to
the bishop
but the bishop can't take the rook for
the same reason
the bishop is guarding this square and
now
oops
whoops
so you can't do anything about that um
you can't take it with the bishop so
queen takes g5 was played
and the rook went right back to h5
you still can't take it because this
knight is coming in and in this position
black resigned
it's brutal it's
so and all of that stems from just the
power of this knight right e5 was a
strategic mistake it blocked this bishop
and made it have to like just sit back
here and it can't guard everything
because the knight is just happily
sitting here in the middle if you notice
so black resigns here um
in this game
the power of the outpost is so big that
on move 20
so earlier white white sacrificed the c4
pawn to get this outpost on move 20 the
knight came to d5
and it was so powerful there that it
didn't even have to move the rest of the
game every thread it made was implicit
white never even had to move it
because it was doing so much
it's allowing us to sack a rook to gain
more space
again we can do the same thing
and there's just nothing so
black resin in this position
with the idea that if they continue
and just keep trying to keep their queen
we could play something like queen to h1
threatening to bring our rook to to uh
g1 and pin the queen to the king and
threatening to play rook to h8
you cannot stop both threats
something like bishop to g7 doesn't work
it's defending h8 and it's helping the
king escape but once again this bishop
is doing a job
the knight's too powerful
so
there's your word to the wise uh
if you can get an outpost at night
it's real strong
one of the great benefits so watch out
for any opportunities where your
opponent has a backwards pawn and no
pieces right the key here to set this up
what white did is they systematically
removed all of the pieces that could
challenge this knight
and they did that after they saw that
there were no pawns here so if all of
those conditions are true it's a really
good idea
all right so we got about uh so
arcane doctrine do i see these moves in
my games you know sometimes um it's
easier to see the moves once you like
have the knight on d5 i don't know that
i'd be playing some of those crazy
sacrifices but
but one day you can work towards it
so let's wrap up with another really
beautiful
benefit of having a knight is the knight
can deliver checkmate in a way that no
other piece can
since it can jump it can do what's
called the smothered mate
and a smothered mate is essentially
where black's king is fully trapped by
their own pieces
and we're going to use our knight to
deliver a check that jumps over all of
those pieces and attacks
so in this position it's white to move
and white looks like they're in a bit of
trouble
because black has an extra pawn and a
rook for their knight so black's up
materially and
white's queen's not defended where
blacks is
and if the queen moves too far away
then black's gonna come down here and
call checkmate with a back rank so we
gotta be really careful as white but
because it's our turn and because of the
power of the night we can actually win
this game
so white to move
i don't want to hazard an idea of how we
can
not only make progress but actually win
this game
well so our first problem is our queen's
not defended so if we just move a pawn
we don't actually have time to play a
move like this we're going to lose our
queen
so we need to do something
fast we don't have a lot of time to
spare
so wandless mugo sees the first few
moves
our first idea is knight takes f7
the idea here is it looks like this
knight is uh you could take it with the
rook
but if they did what would white play
yeah so it's important if they decided
to take our knight we don't want to take
the rook we want to take the queen
this rook was defending the queen but
it's not anymore and this will lead the
rook to have to come back and we get a
checkmate if we take the rook
uh we actually get into checkmate
ourselves you gotta be careful of this
back rank
so you cannot take with the rook
uh because it undefends the queen so the
only move here is king to g8
and then a really powerful tactic a
discovered check and a double check
knight to h6
we attack the king with the knight and
we attack the king with the queen
so even though both of these pieces are
undefended
you can't take one because then the
other would still be calling check
so because of that uh we can't take the
knight we can't take the queen
uh the king has to go back to h8
and in this position we could choose to
opt for a draw we could repeat moves
forever because there's never a chance
right black's never going to want to
give up this work for the night and lose
the game
so they will continue to repeat
so at least we gotta draw
but we can do a little better than that
so remembering the idea i just talked
about of a smothered mate if we can get
black to be fully trapped in their own
pieces
our knight will be able to deliver a
checkmate
so how can we do it queen to f7
suggested the problem is if we're not
making a direct threat then there's
always backrank ideas
if you don't know the square name just
kind of describe where it's going um
uh over here
so
if we're not attacking the king then
they're gonna keep getting their back
rank so a few people in chat have the
right idea
queen to g8
sacrificing the queen
but because it's defended by the knight
the king cannot take the rook must and
now the king is fully smothered
meaning
this is checkmate
so even though he gave up our queen the
knight able to jump over these pieces
attack the king and the king can't move
through their own pieces this is no
other piece can do a smothered mate only
the knight
let's look at a couple other examples
i've shown this before i think i showed
this last week so i'm not going to go
too much into it
but this is from the budapest gambit and
it's going to show a similar
trap
white sacrifices a pawn on e5 early on
to gain some initiative
and keep forcing light to respond
check
knight to d2
attacks again
a3 attacking the bishop and here black
can make the sacrificial move
knight takes e5 allowing black to
capture the bishop because if they do
we have the same trick
black to move what's the best move in
this position
knight to d3 with the same idea last
week we were talking about it with pins
once the knight moves this queen is
unlocked
this pawn is pinned and cannot capture
meaning
knight to d3 is checkmate
the queen locks the pawn down and the
king is fully trapped in its own pieces
really brutal checkmate um
and i want to show one more example here
this is from the game of the century so
this was between donald byrne and bobby
fisher
and this was
uh
essentially called out as like a
breaking out moment for bobby fischer
people were like that he was i think 13
years old at the time
and he played this incredible game and
this position was black to move and he
played the move uh let's see i'm gonna
make sure i have this right
yeah rook f to e8 check king to f1 and
then he plays bishop to e6 giving up his
queen because of a crazy long variation
where if you take the queen you're still
losing we don't have to go into all of
that
um
but
instead of taking the queen
donald byrne chose to take uh this
bishop here
and in this position uh white played
some really sorry black played some
really beautiful moves
black started with queen to b5 check
now
in this game the king went to g1
if the king had gone to e1 uh what would
black have continued with
e2 yeah um rook takes e6 is a good move
but it's not as good as checkmate
so the king can never come back over
here because this knight is gonna allow
our queen to call checkmate so that's
why in the game king went to g1
so how did bobby fischer make progress
in this position
this is really where it starts
queen sacrifice where do you want to
sack the queen queen to
f6 f3
f1
so queen to f1
looks great there's a bit of a problem
queen to f1 if the knight takes our
queen
then this is a smothered mane
but the king can also take
so you always have to be careful right
queen f1 looks good but
rook takes is not forced
so what do we have to do instead
we have to do we have to do a little
setup to get our queen onto f1
yeah over here
not over here because it's not involving
the king
uh but yeah someone in the chat my name
is buffalo
uh yes knight to e2 first
so this is check and this is going to
set up the same pattern you might
recognize
now the king has to move back right
there's nothing that can take this
knight so the king goes to f1
and now
this might look a little familiar
what should white or sorry what should
black play here
a plus in any notation means check
so if you see plus end notation it means
check
so what should black play here
knight f4
okay
if knight f4
came back to g1
so you're close 926 andy in the chat has
the right idea we're gonna do double
check again knight to g3
you can't take it again because it's a
double check
and in this position it's the same as
before the kink still can't go to e1
because then it's mate here on e2
so the king has to go back to g1 now
and now
yeah now that our knight is in this
position here's the important part is
the knight is defending the f1 square
meaning when we put our queen here on f1
you can't take with the king this is
what uh messed us up when we tried to
play queen f1 first last time so now
because the knight is defending you have
to take with the rook
and this game ended with the beautiful
knights to e2
smothered checkmate the king is fully
trapped
uh so
very quickly to humor arcane doctrine i
i won't try and explain all of this but
just for fun um what would have happened
if after bishop to e6 right the point of
bishop to e6 is bobby fischer wanted to
draw this bishop away so he could
deliver check and get this beautiful
smothered mate
instead
had black chosen there's our headwhite
chosen to take the queen here's what
could have happened we would have seen a
similar kind of discover check idea
so bishop takes check
king can't go to e1 now because the rook
is open on this file so king to g1
check
and we can gobble up a pawn check
and go to c3
and now a takes b6 hitting the queen
the knight is defended
queen drops back
and instead of taking the rook now uh
bobby could have played rook to a4
attacking the queen again defended by
the knight and defending the bishop all
of these pieces are defended once the
queen moves away
then you take the rook
and it's a really weird imbalanced
position um where
there's a knight for a knight and a rook
for a rook
uh and
a rook and two bishops for a queen
but black
or sorry white's king is so kind of just
lost in the corner there's back back
rank threats at some point um all of
black's pieces are super active and
white's rook is totally stuck in the
corner so the advantage definitely goes
to uh bobby in this position so so
that's why uh white chose not to take
the bishop or sorry not to think the
queen but still kind of crazy that they
saw all of that um
but that's kind of the idea and that's
why in the game instead of taking the
queen bishop here was played which then
allows the smothered mating pattern and
just to show it one more time
the king can never go to e1 because of
checkmate on e2
so king moves away the knight comes in
with check
king moves back and now the key move
double check hitting the king with two
pieces so you can't take the knight
again the king moves back and now you
can sacrifice the queen defended
so that the king can't take rook takes
and checkmate
so that's uh really all the time we have
today but want to thank everybody in the
chat key things to remember with the
knight this smothered mate because the
knight can jump
we also looked at outposts so anytime
you can get a knight on one of these
outposts where it can't be challenged by
another piece or by a pawn
really really strong
and then just generally forks right
always being aware of opportunities to
get your opponent's pieces uh in a nice
forked position not just with a night
but with any piece
so with that thank you all for joining
hope to see you again next week this has
been beginner breakdown please take